at what age did you start sorting your
life
out it's a good
question I think the moment where I
began to really look Inward and take
stock and inventory of my
life legitimately for the first time was
probably when I was
31 and found myself in a treatment
center in rural or again uh faced with
confronting uh a decade plus uh problem
with drugs and alcohol uh nowhere to
escape just a bunch of
counselors and a bucolic Countryside and
a 100 days
to really start to
understand why I had ended up in this
place which certainly was not the plan
for my life life I can tell you uh and
what I was going to do about it in order
to create a new life for myself that
would be more in alignment with a truer
version of who I was I didn't know the
answer to that question but that's where
that very long journey probably began
consciously it seems to me that a good
chunk of your story is a series of re
ventions yes I think that we are all
Reinventing ourselves all the time I've
said this before but I think the great
delusion that we walk around with is
that we are in some kind of Perpetual
stasis We Are The Way We Are The World
is the way that it is this person
behaves this way they're always going to
behave that way uh but the reality is
that everything is changing all the time
from the subatomic level all the way to
you know the vastness of the universe
there is no stasis everything is in flux
and and is in motion um the question is
how much are you directing that change
versus uh reacting to the world around
you um and yes my life has been
punctuated by a couple kind of
significant Rubicon changes or or
reinventions uh to be sure um but I'm
always in the process of trying to
evaluate where I'm at where I want to be
where I want to head to uh but yeah I've
had a couple sort of uh moments in my
life that uh were sort of uh Line in the
Sand moments for sure yeah you have this
really famous tweet talking about all of
the things you've done successfully and
the fact that you didn't do them before
a particular age hadn't started my
podcast until I hadn't run my first
endurance race until I didn't write my
first book until and I think in a
an age where social media allows us to
see successes from people very young um
it gives a good bit of Solace to people
who uh feel like I'm 40 now I've missed
I'm in the I'm on the back nine and I
haven't even started swinging the golf
club yet I know what that feels like you
know I was that guy certainly you can
always reinvent yourself there's always
hope there's always opportunity I think
now more than ever with all the tools
that are available to people to craft
their own career paths to find ways to
support themselves through uh Pursuits
that that they're curious about or that
light them up I think this is a real
golden age in terms of that uh but that
didn't exist when I was your age or when
I was younger and I grew up in a very
traditional household education was
Paramount expectations were set very
high and I learned early and often how
to play that game of upward Mobility I
was an awkward insecure kid who had
difficulty making friends but at some
point I locked in on the sport of
swimming and that's a whole story I'm
happy to go into and what I learned in
the swimming pool transferred into the
classroom and I became a better student
I had always struggled in school but by
the time I graduated from high school I
was top of my class and got very good at
playing the game of getting into all the
colleges and going to the right place
and getting the right job without ever
any self-reflection on what it was that
I wanted to do or what excited me or
what was unique about me or how I wanted
to show up in the world or express
myself uh I was just trying to Excel and
that path was very narrow at the time
like go to this school get this job show
up early work late you know sort of
climbed that corporate ladder went to
law school was on the partnership track
and a law firm did all of that and had
to basically suffer an existential and
Health crisis as a reckoning in order to
look inward on myself and reflect
upon the the reasons why I made those
decisions why they were leading me
astray and begin the process of opening
the apperture of my vision
to to allow space for something new and
different what do you
think people get wrong about reinvention
like what is it that the people who fail
to turn their life around
do I think people think it's a magic
trick they snap their fingers they make
a decision and their life is different
overnight I think there's a lack of
appreciation
of everything that goes into the moment
where you change your mind and you do
something different and then all of the
work that goes in to that rebuilding
phase in the aftermath of making that
decision that ultimately creates the new
life I think people are impatient they
want results too quickly they don't
appreciate the amount of hard work that
goes into actually crafting the life of
your desires and I think as a result of
that that when they don't see results
immediately they burn out and Retreat to
what's safe and what they know versus
welcoming failure welcoming uncertainty
getting comfortable with risk and
remaining persistent in their Vision to
create something more in alignment with
their authentic self I think one of the
big problems especially when it comes to
reinvention is in the Rocky movies the
Montage of training is two and a half
minutes long in reality it can be a
decade mhm
and I think getting really visceral with
what tough times feel
like helps people who are going through
them to not feel so personally cursed
while they're going through them you're
not sure that the difficult thing that
you're struggling with at the moment the
the um breaking of habits of hanging
around with people who don't want the
best for you who you're getting out a
bad relationship you maybe want to move
and leave home and your parents don't
want you to whatever it might be you
don't even
have the reassurance that there's going
to be glory on the other side of this
and it doesn't feel as polished or as
triumphant or even as Noble it just
feels like confusing and dark and messy
and like destitute and you know even in
portrayals of alcoholism and and of of
addiction it's really difficult to
capture in popular Cinema just how
like mundanely desperate it is there
like there's not even any glory in the
demise so to speak and I think
that hearing about the challenges that
people go through during
reinvention
helps everybody to feel like
incapable of doing
it that's why we love personal Stories
We love hearing stories of people who uh
met a certain fate and figured out how
to rebuild their life um I think they're
they're is something infectious about
that that does give people hope for
themselves but I think you're correct
when you look in the rearview mirror
everything looks like it lined up
perfectly to create this situation where
I'm sitting across from you right now
but I can tell you as some somebody who
has weathered more than a few large
personal changes in my life it is a very
confusing protracted time and it takes a
lot longer than people realize there's a
lot of confusion there's a lot of
self-doubt there's a lot of judgment
from other people if you're breaking
outside of a social expectation or a
familial expectation if you're trying
something new your peers your friends
are going to look at you a little bit
differently perhaps they're not going to
be as supportive as you might have
expected so there's a loneliness I think
that that that um is part of it as well
and I think with
that is this testing process around your
level of willingness around your level
of trust in yourself and it's like
being burned in a cauldron like you have
I've said as I've said many times
like if you're going to be a phoenix you
have to burn first and I don't know if
there's an and run around that burning
process because that is the process that
you know creates the new version of
yourself it's almost mandatory that one
goes through their version of that so
I've been tested financially emotionally
mentally physically
um and I think I'm wired for it as a
result of my background the way I was
raised my experiences in swimming I feel
I feel like well equipped to kind of
handle that but I've been brought to my
knees more than once and I can tell you
in those
moments all you feel is fear and this
overpowering impulse to retreat back to
what you know and it is in those moments
those are the moments of truth that no
one sees uh where you're at your
breaking point and that's where faith
comes in honestly you have to believe in
yourself you have to be able to hold
that Vision uh
for the better life of your
aspirations and you have to also have an
almost Transcendent
self transcend you have to have an
almost Transcendent sense of some other
Force at play that has your best
interest at heart such that if your
heart is true and you are truly engaged
in the process of trying to align your
actions with your values and you have
excavated your soul and done the
interior work to try to really get
honest with yourself and you're Earnest
in that regard I do believe that the
universe will at some point conspire to
support you it's not going to be on your
timeline it's not going to be convenient
the results aren't going to look like
you think they're going to look um but
I've seen this play out in my life many
times and and in the lives of of many
people that I'm close with yeah there's
a a cool quote from Naval that says
Karma doesn't need quantum energy or
spiritual woo to be real karma is just
you repeating your patterns virtues and
flaws until you finally get what you
deserve and I think that you know it
doesn't matter how secular you want to
get with it
that if you continue to stack the deck
against yourself the only way that you
end up winning is purely by fluke and
that chance of fluke begins to get
increasingly minuscule and the reverse
is true as well one of the challenges
especially when it comes to reinvention
is your f an uphill battle it's the most
difficult time and you have the least
amount of evidence to have faith in
yourself you've never done this before
you've
never actually stuck to the diet for
seven days you've never actually been
able to go sober or stay loyal to a
partner or turn up on time to a job pick
whatever it is or take it all the way up
to the top you've never been able to
truly have a difficult conversation with
somebody you know at your business
you've never really been able to sit
down with your business partner at this
big company that you've built for 15
years and tell them that this isn't
working you've kind of sort of nudged
towards it and blah blah
blah reinvention I think happens on
really small and really large
scales well it happens small until it
happens big uh the reinvention occurs in
the micro actions that you're taking
every single day uh the tiny little
things that that perhaps no one even
notices that are creating muscle memory
around new behaviors that perhaps are
very comfortable to you like hey I'm
going to engage with this person in a
different way that I than I usually do
by being more direct or more honest or
I'm going to put down a boundary or I'm
going to say no to this and yes to this
tiny little things repeated over time is
what produces dramatic change and it's
like this curve you know it's like this
very slow curve until it asima toes up
and everyone wants to talk about the
pivot moment when it goes Skyward but
the truth is the real work is in the
drudgery correct and the difficult
Anonymous work of shoveling every
single day um in sobriety they say don't
leave before the miracle and I take that
as a lesson in in persistence whatever
it is that you're you're pursuing to
achieve or or create or Express in the
world I think a lot of people back out
before that happens and I think you're
right now you're a perfect example of
this you're experiencing this with your
show you're having some large growth at
the moment
um and I think you even shared something
about the fact that you've been doing
this for a very long time and most
people may have backed out a long time
ago backed out before the miracle occurs
or the growth spurt or whatever it is so
for me it always comes back to
perseverance persistence uh High pain
tolerance um and ability to suffer
through discomfort a welcoming of doing
hard things and uh and will willingness
really you know and that's a lesson that
I learned in sobriety sobriety isn't for
people that need it it's for people that
want it and one of the first things
someone will be asked when they enter
the the kind of ecosystem of recovery is
what are you willing to do what are you
willing to do different how willing are
you are you willing to make this your
number one priority and a lot of people
will put words to that but only time
will tell whether those words are
followed up by the ACT that demonstrates
the level of willingness that is
required to actualize anything of
meaning in this
world with respect to nal's quote the
only push back I would give to that is
this idea that um that one is deserving
or that one is entitled to anything
you're not entitled to anything you
don't necessarily deserve anything all
you have control over is how you direct
your attention and how you comport
yourself what are the actions that
you're taking how you're responding to
the world around you and when you drill
that down into the tiniest little things
that you're doing every single day and
try to repeat that with just rigorous
Relentless um
consistency that is how you move
mountains that's how you build mountains
that's how you change your life and that
is not something that's going to trend
on Twitter it's not sexy there's nothing
sexy about it it sucks and I
wish it wasn't that way and throughout
all of my re inventions and the changes
um that I've made in my life I didn't do
them willingly I did them because I was
in so much pain that I was boxed
into a corner and felt like the only way
out was through in other words when the
pain of my circumstance exceeded the
tremendous amount of fear that I was
harboring about doing something
different doing something that would
change the the outcomes because if
you're if you're doing something in a
certain certain way and you're always
getting the same outcome another
recovery Trope uh that's the very def
definition of addiction right like until
you start doing things differently
you're always going to get the same
result and yet we're
so um calcified around who we are and
what we're doing and this is my identity
and this is who I am that it becomes
very difficult to break free of that and
to live in a more fluid state where
where you are in the process of always
trying to deconstruct the belief that
you hold uh and and and and really get
honest with yourself about the fallacy
of the identity that you hold so dear
what are lower
companions lower companions is another
term uh from recovery uh As the adage
goes uh as you pursue your drinking or
using career uh it starts out fun drugs
work right it's a good time drinking is
pretty reliable it's going to produce a
certain kind of effect right and
alcoholics and drug addicts
um they don't become addicts because
it's dysfunctional on day one they do it
because it's feeling a need it is doing
something positive in their life in my
case it made
me feel like myself it was like wrapping
myself in a warm blanket where all my
insecurities and my fears would vanish
and I was able to be a social person in
Social settings which was something that
was very difficult for me my whole life
and it functioned that way for quite
some time until it didn't and then your
life slowly starts to
degrade you start making decisions that
you rationalize that aren't in your best
interest it becomes a little lonelier
the chaos Factor starts to increase the
uh negative repercussions of your
behavior start to stack and
escalate uh it starts to get
uncomfortable your higher companions
your good friends the people that love
you who have your best interest at heart
start to flee from the hills and you
begin to search out other people who are
vibrating at your wavelength who are not
going to give you a hard time for your
behavior and are more than happy to do
the thing that you want to do which is
to get loaded or get high
so you find yourself in really
compromising strange sometimes scary
situations with people you would not
ordinarily hang out with because you
share this one thing which is you just
want to lose yourself in this substance
or perhaps with people who are addicted
to um a certain Behavior it could be
gambling it could be you know it's like
anything you're going to find people who
are going to coign whatever Behavior it
is uh and then as the addiction
escalates even more you start to run
through those people even they don't
want to hang out yeah you get lower and
lower and lower and lower until there's
maybe that one guy and if not you're
just home alone in a dark room with the
shades pulled down um and that's how it
ended for me for sure we'll get back to
talking to rich in one minute but first
I need to tell you about element element
is a tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
it's got a science back electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
you might ask what do I want with an
electrolyte drink well it'll regulate
your appetite it'll curb Cravings it'll
help improve your brain function best of
all it tastes phenomenal first thing in
the morning this orange element salt in
water is outstanding your adenosine
system that caffeine acts on isn't even
active for the first 90 minutes of the
day so it's pointless having a morning
coffee your adrenal system which is what
salt acts on is active so this will make
you feel more alert more awake and
improve your hydration best of all all
they've got a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy it and if
you do not like it for any reason they
will give you your money back that's how
confident they are that you'll love it
head to drink LM nt.com slod wisdom to
get a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box that's drink
LM nt.com
slod wisdom the idea of lower companions
although not uh super romantic I think
is really useful and the first time I'd
ever heard of it was from you and I
think that even for the people that
don't have a substance addiction
dependency the idea of of people who
don't have your best interests at heart
who don't make you show up as your
better self the self that you wish that
you were more of the time I think
there's something to take from that
and you know I met across my nightclub
promoting career I met about a million
people face to face stood on the front
door of nightclubs sure you met a lot of
alcoholics and drug addicts correct
yeah and a lot of people that and and in
that position 10 p.m. to 1:00 a.m.
outside of a night club it's all the
romance and none of the destitution
right because it's full of energy
they've got the girls on their arm or
the the their girlfriends are with them
and you see them go in upright and you
see them come out horizontal um who's
the guy who comes out
last yeah I was that guy yeah well yeah
the idea of lower companions I just
think there's a lot of people that
listen to the show and this is one of
the things like if you want to make me
cry by sending me a me this isn't a
request but the messages that I get that
make me weep or tear up the most are
ones where people say something like hey
man like I'm a a ice hockey player from
rural Canada and I'm 23 and none of my
friends understand me and when I listen
to your show I feel less Alone um I
can't talk to any of my friends about
like what I'm interested in all that
they want to do is keep doing the same
thing every weekend the idea
of self-actualization he getting a bag
in with the boys on the weekend right
and that
is you know it's a even more in some
ways maybe an even more
pernicious type of lower companion
because there's not there's not even the
red flag flying above their head do you
know what I mean yeah it's not
necessarily a bad influence it's just uh
at best neutral or perhaps somebody
who's um insidiously but very gradually
undermining the quality of that comp
life like you I also get a lot of those
types of messages and it's very
meaningful to me and I think what you're
speaking about is super important of
course there's that adage you're the
average of the five people oh sorry
average of the five podcasts you listen
probably right but I think it it is
worthy of
examination this topic
because most
people
just end up in the environment that
they're in and they never try to be in
the in the pilot share of how they're
directing their Community there's a lot
of talk about mentors I want this person
to be my mentor I want Tony Robbins to
be my mentor Gary ve or you know choose
your choose your person um but the truth
is each and every one of us in our
community is surrounded by people that
are wiser than us in various ways people
that can help
us and the nature of that Community can
be crafted and cultivated by you with a
little mindful intention people are good
they want to help people I know that I
feel good when I'm helping somebody that
is the my primary purpose as a sober um
person is to help other alcoholics to
achieve sobriety and that is the source
of um my greatest sense of self when I'm
in that process uh so I think to the
extent that you can engage with the
people around you from a place of
Greater mindfulness and and exercise
some discretion about the people that
you're spending time with and not just
go with the flow because these are the
dudes in the locker room or what have
you I think you're you're getting
yourself way ahead of the game and
listen not everybody has a lot of
high-minded people around them and I
think it's you know important to to you
know note that and that's why shows like
yours and podcasts that are out there I
think are so important when I was your
age and when I was young younger I mean
when I was a young man trying to figure
out my way in the world and who I wanted
to be there was no internet I couldn't
dial up a podcast and listen to people
tell stories about their careers or or
how they overcame hardship or how they
did what they did and and and I'm a guy
who's embarrassingly well educated and
yet that was not available to me so when
I'm creating a show and I know you do
this as well I'm very conscious of that
person who lacks community in their
respective
region um and trying to make tools
available to that person that they
ordinarily wouldn't have access to and
it's incredibly powerful it's such a
gift there's an enormous library of
people sharing their stories about how
they did what they did or why they chose
this career and why it's important to
them and and how they think about their
relationships and and what it means to
you know be a man or be a woman and and
you know walk the planet with integrity
and those are the things that I'm always
thinking about in terms of the
conversations that I'm having like I
want to put out that high vibration but
to your
point choose your companions wisely and
if your friends are not raising the
vibration of what you're trying to
achieve or they're just giving you
and making fun of you and whenever
you're Earnest and share a goal or a
dream they put you down it might be time
to upgrade and that's harsh uh and
there's Grace ways of doing that but I
think it's important to seek out people
who support you and find older people
who are a little bit further down the
path who can say here's how I did it or
I see where you're struggling um plenty
of those people are around and it
doesn't have to be one person I think
everybody should have a board of
advisers or a council of directors like
I don't call um when I'm having a an
issue in my marriage uh I will call one
person but when I'm having a
professional issue or an issue around
sobriety that's going to be an entirely
different person everybody comes with
their own unique set of experiences and
and wisdom and you know AC crude
knowledge as a result of how they live
their life uh and these are not famous
people they're just people in my
community they're friends that I've
chosen simply you know in many ways
because of the vibration that they carry
and and the way that they hold themsel
out into the world and I can tell you
somebody who's been practicing that for
a very long time it's improved my life
in ways I couldn't possibly tabulate
like it is incredibly important who you
spend your time with I uh tweeted this a
little while ago saying I'm in the very
fortunate position
where most of my friends are also my
role models and that's not that my role
models are my friends right it's the
other way around it's that the people
that I have I'm friends with in the UK
in America
America people that are Beyond mundanely
normal do things that on
a dinnerly basis I look at and I go
that's extraordinary like the way that
they dealt with a difficult conversation
that they had to have the way that they
made an awkward decision with regards to
their business where somebody wasn't
fitting and they said it in the the the
right way early with courage and bravery
uh you know right up to
my housemate had his uh a clip from his
YouTube channel shared on Rogan a couple
of days ago so like he's fired up for
that I'm like you know each of these
different people like extraordinary in
some ways and unbelievably normal in
many many more ways um and I understand
you know if this
is if you're listening to this and it's
triggering a little bit of something
inside of you going well it must be nice
you know living in Austin Texas or
Calabasas or whatever and you're
surrounded by all these people and you
know you've got interest in Blu ticks
knocking on your door asking to be
friends I I I I do get that
but the bottom line is that you
will
devolve to the lowest common denominator
amongst the friend group that you're
in and if you have the luxury of being
able to sit and listen to pontificating
podcasts for like two hours you are
probably built to take charge of that
situation and I would bet you that there
are a really non- insignificant number
of people that live within three miles
of you who all would love to do the same
thing and yeah
I met about a million people across my
nightlife career and had a handful of
friends um that's because a lot of the
guys that worked with us came and went
they moved on to different careers Club
promo isn't a typically a long-term
career um and I realized that my funnel
exposure to conversion friend ratio was
your funnel to conversion friend ratio
so think about how wide that's such like
a bro science term we're right this
welcome welcome to my podcast welcome to
my podcast Rich um the size of people
that I was reaching compared with the
number of friends that I had understood
was so I couldn't believe it right and I
was like okay something's up like this
is the I something is up and what it was
largely my fault and the reason that it
was my fault was that I was behaving in
a way that I thought would make other
people like
me and what that meant was the people
who did like me I didn't actually truly
like in large
part and the people who I would have
liked saw this
person that wasn't any yeah you become
you're unlikable to those people yes I'm
unlikable to the people that I would
like right for precisely the reason I'm
playing this person role right um water
rises to its own
level and you can't transmit something
you haven't got another recovery adage
which basically means it basically means
if you're trying to befriend
somebody because they have something
that you want um and you try to pretend
that you're at their level to say
whatever it is you think they want to
hear from you so that they feel
comfortable befriending you it's very uh
transparent that that is a false and
shallow gesture right like you can't if
you're sitting behind a microphone and
you're pontificating about a whole bunch
of but it's not a result of
earned experience in your own life then
it's not going to have the resonant
effect that you think
it would have because
you didn't earn it right
so in recovery it means walking your
talk basically and when you walk your
talk and that talk and that walk is
integrated with a value system that is
slowly improving your life then the
water in your glass raises and the level
of your companions will raise in lock up
with that so I think it's important that
if you want to attract a certain caliber
of person into your life then you have
to live your life in accordance with the
kinds of values that would be attractive
to that person and it's somebody who's
spoken a lot about dating like this is
the same thing with relationships right
you're not going to attract that mate
who is living a more aspirational life
than you until you can level up your own
life there's a quote from Alex homoi
that says people are attracted to all
authenticity but it's hard to Define for
me here's my best attempt true alignment
of what you think what you say and what
you do the hardest part is realizing
that our thoughts are and that we
have to fix them instead of Faking the
next
two MH what we think what you say and
what you do and a lot of the time you do
and say things that you don't think in
an attempt to try and be liked I know
that you had a background in school of
bullying and this is something that I
still need to dig into more but that was
like that was childhood for me largely
that was school and um like loneliness
like again there wasn't even any
Glory or Triumph in
the in the loneliness or in the in the
like solitary nature it was very mundane
very
vanilla sadness yeah right and I think
what the undertone that that taught me
was fundamentally the world won't love
you unless you can offer it something
because before you didn't have anything
to offer it and it didn't love you so
now you need to offer it something which
is why if I look back on the career that
I went through in my 20s every single
thing that I did had a ton of
social uh monetary value on the other
side of it so I became a model before I
came to UNI then I kept working as a
commercial model and then moved into
editorial then I became a club promoter
because people like models people really
like Club promoters you want to get in
VIP you want to skip the queue you want
to know where the prettiest girls are
you want a free bottle of champagne you
got to come through me okay then I
became a DJ DJ literally makes the crowd
have this Collective FF Essence Al
together then I go on two reality TV
shows right two reality TV shows
Bluetick on Twitter free chocal
toothpaste full works because maybe if I
can acrw sufficient Social
Capital the world will actually
feel believe that I'm worth something
and where and at what point did you have
a Reckoning with that like where did the
bottom fall out on that for you so I got
to this second reality TV show and what
I'd been doing for a long time was
playing a Persona like my business
partner knew who I was truly and the
guys that worked with me knew who I was
truly but largely the public facing
Chris wasn't honest about his curiosity
about the person he was but I was always
able to sedate myself with distraction
with YouTube and social media and
partying and girls and stuff right and
then I go on this TV show and they take
everything away from you there's no
books there's no calls home there's no
internet no phone no TV no nothing and
all that you have to do for a month
is talk to people who are the hyper
extroverted party people that I thought
I was so I got delivered what I call a
fatal dose of contrast I saw staring me
in the face
inescapable a team of 13 other people
who were the person that I'd been
pretending to be for a decade and I
realized that I wasn't that and I
thought okay I I literally can't escape
this and it wasn't that and the sky over
and then I realized that my true path
was to become a podcaster and talk
into a microphone wasn't like that but
it did make me think right there's
something up here like there is a in
congruence between the person you say
you are and who that that sort of person
actually is and that really was the
beginning of it rolling downhill but
again even with that you said it before
like life needs to be lived forward but
only makes sense in Reverse mhm
and when you're staring into a bunch of
unknown it's there's no romance there is
no glory medley like real that
you got some cool like Jamie Fox
motivational quote over the top of it
telling you about where you're going to
go no and you can't put it on a calendar
you know the end point of this because
you don't even know which direction
you're heading you're flailing before
you find any kind of trajectory for
yourself and I think it requires you
know a deep level of commitment to self
and again Faith to walk a path where you
don't know what the the next brick is
going to look like that's getting laid
down in front of you and I think a lot
of people want to know what the
destination is before they take that
first step and that's why they never get
out of the gate uh but I think um you
know your story makes perfect sense mine
is certainly analogous
um I was bullied but it was very vanilla
there's nothing like super interesting
about that other than it was pretty much
as you would expect it but I think as a
result of
that my interior experience was to feel
like being myself was not safe or okay I
was already insecure and
so as a survival mechanism you have to
figure out a costume or a mask to wear
to avoid the pitfalls of being bullied
and just survive and navigate the day
that's certainly what I did and like you
it showed up in people pleasing I'm a
chronic people pleaser only in recent
years have I really worked hard to try
to deconstruct that um and it's
something that that is also pernicious
because um the lie you tell yourself is
like I'm a nice guy like I just want
everyone to be happy and so you go out
of your way to make everyone else happy
but as a result of that none of your own
needs are getting met met you're
developing resentment you're
disconnected from who you are it's also
I think you're not bothered about making
them happy you're just desperate for
them to like you yes that's the fuel
underneath the whole thing and it's an
empty fuel because then you get it it
never Sates the appetite though there's
a quote from or Marcus where he says the
Persona is incapable of receiving love
it can only receive praise and what he
means by that is if you're playing a
role any of the accolades that you get
and of the care that people give toward
you isn't going to hit you existentially
it's like people don't love Russell Crow
they love Gladiator people don't love
Chris Hemsworth they love Thor and this
is how you can feel alone in a crowd and
Hollow in Victory because if you do a
thing without genuinely putting yourself
into it whenever people praise it and I
can promise you I have tried I have been
there I have achieved the things that
haven't been existentially connected to
me
mhm
and I didn't feel satisfied right i' I'd
achieved in my 20s pretty much all of
the things that Society tells a young
man that he should take pride and
pleasure and and fulfillment from right
like Renown and girls and and money all
this stuff not a I'm Dan bills
Arian but like just a just an acceptable
normal person amount of that that would
put you close to the top of the
tree didn't fulfill me it didn't fulfill
me and I could have done it for eons and
it still wouldn't have fulfilled me I
love and I'm proud of all of the things
I did in terms of the business but
that's not that's not what Society told
me it wasn't about I was never told you
are going to adore working until 3 in
the morning with your business partner
trying to get this copyrighting exactly
right so that you can do a thing that's
that's cool in your business what they
said was you should leave at 1:00 a.m.
and go to the cool Afterparty because
that's where people are going to see see
you and that's and that wasn't the case
and I it was really really tough I'm
glad you know thinking about the time
when you were that age and my age
now had it not have been for influences
that that I did get access to on YouTube
and podcasts and stuff like that I don't
know where I would have been given a
different frame I don't know how I would
have been ripped out of it so that
hole that you were trying to fill what
does that look like
now a good question I I I ask
myself sometimes in my
more uncertain moments whether I've
replaced offering
people my Instagram followers and Q jump
in a nightclub for uh cool quotes and
photos of me with Jordan
Peterson I ask myself that
sometimes the difference
is when I do
this all I feel is joy and excitement
and that's the lead indicator I think
that I'm doing something right I'm not
thinking about look at how many plays
this is going to get I'm fired up
because I get to sit down with Rich and
have a cool conversation about
this thing and I it's genuinely how I
feel I did this three-hour podcast with
hosi yesterday and I'm sat there
grinning to myself like a idiot just
thinking this is so much fun like if you
asked me to do anything else right now
anything you could offer me to do
anything and I wouldn't I wouldn't leave
leave for a family emergency but if it
was something else that was supposed to
be better or more fun I wouldn't leave
and I don't know like that just using
that as a heuristic seems like a good
start and I think a lot of the time
especially young guys lost young
guys they do
things that they think other people will
think are cool or will think are
impressive and when you actually ask
them M how much joy do you take from
this I don't really have a particularly
satisfactory
answer I think that's astute I'm glad
that you found this thing it certainly
wasn't something that you could
have white boarded in the aftermath of
of being on that reality show um it's a
process you know and it's a fluid thing
and I would suggest to you that that
there's more and I think the more um
that you can bring a sensibility of
service uh to what you're
doing that
um sense of of of
wholeness uh and
Oneness and
um and sense of
uh of meaning in your life will only
escalate because truly for me it's all
it's it's all about service you know
what I do is a commercial Enterprise of
course but um when I get away from the
service aspect of it and into the ego
part of it is when I Stray From my
values and that hole starts to gnaw you
know on my soul and just to kind of go
back um to you know my version of your
story you
mentioned uh that Aubrey quote about
praise and love and I think for me as a
young person those two things were one
and the same I lived in a house
where
love was
essentially conditioned upon achievement
and I got good at achievement but I did
it
unconsciously in search of love and it
was never enough no matter how much I
achieved no matter how fast I
swam uh I was always just shy of getting
it and it wasn't until adulthood that I
could reflect back on that and have some
self-awareness around it because when
you're young your brain is informed you
don't know why you're I'm competitive
I'm ambitious uh but in truth um I just
wanted to be loved
unconditionally but that was never going
to happen because I was a sensitive
artistic kid who had all these weird
interests and would rather hide in the
corner and read a book but I adopted the
Persona of an athlete and and
academically inclined person and I got
the accolades and I got into all the
schools and perpetuated on that that
hamster wheel as long as I could until
it you know the axle broke and the whole
thing collapsed on top of it of
me in order to you know have a Reckoning
with it and understand
that we don't have to earn love like
love is
unconditional I've got this idea called
insufficiency out adaptation like
imposter adaptation I'm going to read
you this one of the most common tensions
I talk about at the moment is between a
desire for success and a desire to feel
like we're enough success is a strange
thing presumably we want success because
we think a more successful life will
bring us more happiness meaning and
fulfillment here's the problem we
sacrifice the thing we want happiness
for the thing which is supposed to get
it success failure can make you
miserable but I'm not sure success will
make you happy one of the most common
Dynamics I see amongst High performers
is this parents want their to do well
parents encourage their child to do well
by praising when they succeed and
criticizing when they fail the child
learns that praise and admiration is
contingent on succeeding that lesson
metastasizes through early adulthood
into I am only worthy of love acceptance
and belonging if I succeed now powered
by an internal feeling of sufficiency
this person is driven to achieve many
things they're prepared to outwork out
hustle and outs suffer everybody else
because they're not just running toward
a life they want they're running away
from a life that they fear success and
progress ameliorates the feelings of
insufficiency therefore success and
progress become prioritized above
everything
else that sums it
up uh I'm certainly uh somebody who
would fall into that
category
um I've pursued success in a variety of
areas as an
athlete then as a lawyer that was a
disaster um then again as an athlete now
as a podcaster it's it's funny you know
I I I went through like a seven-year
Financial dismantlement like we almost
had our house repossessed I had our cars
repossessed I couldn't pay for the
garbage bins like it was bad and I think
with that was a tremendous amount of em
mascul
emasculation um protect a provider yeah
and a huge um Resurgence of all the
insecurities and fears that I harbored
as a as a as a child and I became
utterly convinced that I was incapable
of success at least financial success I
just I just didn't believe that it was
possible for me when I was a drunk I
could never pay my bills I ruined my
credit then I get sober and I can't
figure out this career thing and I was
as broke as ever and then I'm trying not
even drunk this time trying to I'm not
even drinking and I can't figure it out
and then I'm like oh I'm going to go be
an ultra athlete when I have little kids
in a mortgage there no career path in
that and I just thought
maybe I'm insane like I I honestly
thought like I found I would find myself
you know at
times on a weekday
afternoon at the park with my small
children pushing them on the
swings and having
this dual this tension between these two
ideas on the one hand
recognizing that by leaving the Comforts
of the partnership track on a at a big
Law Firm I had the privilege of being
able to spend time with my young
children in the middle of a weekday
afternoon at this park where there was a
bunch of moms and I'm the only guy while
also believing at the same time that I
was an utter failure because I didn't
know what I was doing with my life I
didn't have a sense of what I should do
or shouldn't do and really starting to
believe that nothing was ever going to
happen for me so this is one of the
problems that I have with the modern
move of asceticism right of of recanting
uh worldly success because I believe
that INB built in almost all
humans is a requirement for the world to
validate them genuinely through actual
achievement and this is another nval
quote where he says it is far easier to
achieve our material desires than to
renounce them and the difference
is had you have had the material
success now
then how much more present would you
have been with your children pushing
them on the
swing well had I had material success
earlier I wouldn't have grown and
evolved mentally emotionally spiritually
and physically
yeah I had to endure that process to be
worthy of the growth curve that I've
been on and frankly you know the the
success that I have now is is
embarrassing because I never would have
thought it possible uh so my
relationship with success now is is very
different than it would have been had I
had I achieved it earlier
or or easier I guess in other news this
episode is brought to you by levels one
of the single biggest predictors of how
long you're going to live and how good
you will feel whilst living is your
metabolic Health the single best way to
understand how your daily decisions are
impacting your longevity and Your
vitality is by tracking your glucose
this is why I wear a continuous glucose
monitor from levels it allows me to
understand in real time whether the
foods that I'm eating are having a
positive or A negative impact on my
health the levels app interprets your
glucose data and provides a simple score
after you eat a meal so that you can see
how different foods impact your health
and develop a diet which is custom and
unpersonalized perfect for your body the
main realization that I had was eating
cereal at any time of the day spikes my
glucose through the roof but if I took a
walk for about 15 minutes I could bring
that back down I would have never
realized this if I hadn't been wearing a
continuous glucose monitor right now
levels has a special offer for my
listeners by going to the link in the
description below or heading to levels.
lmod wisdom that's levels. link slod
wisdom I've heard you
say I still find myself with this sense
that success has to be earned and the
only way to earn it is to inflict pain
on yourself and if you're not in pain
you didn't try hard enough and it would
have been better if you'd suffered more
and I think that's a lie and I want to
find out if it's a lie or if it's
true that resonated with me so
much tell me what you meant by
that I don't think that I'm
particularly
gifted in any kind of traditional way I
don't think
I'm that much smarter than anyone else I
don't think that I'm uh a super talented
athlete uh but if I do if I had to
identify a talent it would be a capacity
to suffer a willingness to do hard
uh and a very high pain tolerance and I
learned this as a young swimmer entering
into uh the kind of Club ecosystem of
swimming in the Northeast where I lived
and realizing quickly as a
13-year-old that I was not the most
talented swimmer that there were a lot
of young gifted swimmers who were much
better than
me but I also realized very
quickly that there was an equation
between work and results
and that equation was pure arithmetic
for me and the more I worked the
narrower that Gap that Talent deficit
Gap became to the point where as a
senior in high school I was one of the
best swimmers in the United States
getting recruited everywhere and was
able to match all of those peers that
previously I thought were much more
talented than me so the message that got
inculcated in my mind was
talent doesn't
matter you have the ability to outwork
everyone in the room that is your gift
and your job is to double down on that
in all areas of your life and this is
what is going to create a trajectory for
you and the truth is it worked it worked
in the pool it worked in the classroom
and I was able to achieve some pretty
amazing things as a young person
outsized results beyond your talent I
was World ranked in the 200 meter
butterfly I went on to Stanford I said
no to Harvard University and went to
Stanford where I was a member of uh a
two-time nc2a championship Squad where
every single day I trained with world
record holders American record holders
nc2a Champions and Olympic gold
medalists these were my athletic Heroes
and by sheer force of will I told myself
I was able to manifest a situation in
which now I was a member of a team in
which I got to spend five hours a day
every single day with the greatest
swimmers in the
sport what does that do to a young mind
it tells it you're capable of anything
but the only way that you're going to
get there is by suffering suffering is
your success equation and I would do
things in the pool in high school that
my coaches to this day still talk about
they're like remember when you did this
set in 1984 like 40 times 200 fly on you
know like I would do Insane sets that no
one else would do because I knew no one
else would do them and I picked the
hardest the the event that creates the
most suffering because that was the
easiest to distinguish myself in and
that was a success equation and so I've
carried that my entire life and to this
day as somebody who doesn't believe
they're particularly talented it's all
the more important that I outwork
everyone in the room and I believe that
in many ways I've done that and I kind
of continue to do it I've done it with
the podcast I've done it with books that
I've written if I don't suffer if I'm
not completely depleted at the end of a
project and I turn it in whether it's a
book or whatever creative thing that I'm
working on then it's not good enough you
have to bleed in order for it to be the
highest expression of what you're
capable of and the truth is through a
lot of therapy a lot of work I have
realized that that is in fact a lie now
untangling that knot and trying to
create new neural Pathways is extremely
uncomfortable what does it feel like if
you sit down and you write something and
you do it from a place of of ease and
presence and awareness and you turn it
in and it didn't cause you to suffer and
you didn't experience pain I'm instantly
going to feel like well that's I
didn't work hard enough for it I didn't
earn it give me that back and let me
rewrite it until 4 in the morning you
know know and I've done this many many
times and then I'll look at it with
Clear Eyes the next day and and realize
you made it worse first draft was better
yeah you made it worse it's a hard pill
to swallow it's been a very difficult
lesson for me to learn it's certainly
not something that I've mastered but I
have created systems in my life that
make that process of
ease um more accessible and and
conducive in my daily schedule to try to
disabuse me of these old patterns that
that are reliable But
ultimately uh are short-term strategies
because they lead to exhaustion and
burnout and disa affectation and all of
these things that are at Cross purposes
with the goal of having any kind of
longevity or continual growth and what
whatever it is that you're trying to do
what are the systems I surround myself
with a team of very talented people so
for a long time I did my podcast which
I've been doing 11 years almost 11 years
at this point for many years I did
almost every single aspect of it myself
my stepson Tyler would edit it but other
than that I handled everything about it
and I was very resistant to letting go
of any aspect of it and letting any
you're laughing letting anybody come in
to help see some of my team over your
show you haveing here right uh but they
know that they have to rip Tas out of my
hand nail my
nail I would rather
forego uh nights of sleep correct than
let any invite anyone else in because
you know what I'm the only one who knows
how to do it I'm the only one who can
get it the way that I want it to be I'm
the only one who's qualified to make it
as good as I know it can be and I'm the
only one who's going to care enough to
go that extra mile to make it great
right and the reason why you're I
know but the reason
why that is
so romantic and Powerful is that there
is some truth in it because no one is
going to care about modern wisdom as
much as you it doesn't matter how much
you pay people or how how talented the
people are that that are around you so
you're faced with a choice either you
loosen the Reigns you let people in you
find people who are better at the
respective skill sets than you are you
train them you Empower them and you get
out of the way and then you are freed up
to do the work that only you can do
which is to prepare for and conduct the
conversations to the best of your
ability everything else can be handled
by someone else in my case I did the
show for years before I I was kicking
and
dragging in order to let go but as a
result of going through that
process I now am able to focus on those
things that are most important and as to
the freedom Point
um the systems that I have in
place create the
added time for the headp space required
to contribute to the creative work that
only I can do and I create rules for
myself like you have to stop after two
hours or you're not allowed to you know
edit while you're writing or you know
you have to put this away and not look
at it for a week like I have to create
stop gaps like a crazy person yeah
exactly because I am a crazy
person Chris I don't know if you know
but I have spent quite a bit of time in
a mental institution so yeah I I'm
certifiable my equivalent of what of the
story that you told with regards to
swimming was with my first business in
night life so I didn't
draw the correlation
between practice and game day ability
throughout my entire athletic career so
I played at a very high level of cricket
because I'm a gentleman and I'm refined
yes uh I played that game that no one
understands or cares about in the United
States well I mean look if you want such
Philistines if you want such Philistines
maybe you would be able to get on
board um I never once I trained a lot
but I trained a lot because it's how I
found my friends and it's what I did it
was habit I never ever had it taught to
me no one ever sat me down and said if
you train you get better and I just I I
didn't feel that lesson I knew that it
was what you was supposed to do but I
just didn't I didn't anyway so I get to
University and we start this events
company and it's the first thing that
I've ever really felt like I excelled at
and got social Renown for so very
quickly I begin to attach sense of
success to the S success of the business
a lot of young especially guys who want
to be accepted if you do have a business
and you do find some success with it you
will do this and it's a pitfall that you
need to be aware of and I imagine it's
the same for girls too
M you do a thing the world tells you
that you are enough or that you it
Praises you because you do the thing
therefore you become the thing so it
wasn't just I run I ran a good or bad
club night last Saturday it was I am a
good or bad person no you're
self-identifying with the achievement as
a referendum on who you are as a person
correct and because I'm British I've got
a Puritan work ethic and what I did was
this was the pentious bit and this is
the pitfall that people really need to
watch out
for I realized that
reliably my the quality of my work was
better if I
suffered therefore if I suffered I
usually got better outcomes
and you feel good about yourself because
you suffered you worked for it you
earned so the lead indicator of what
would be a lagging measure the lead
indicator was suffering the lagging
measure would be success then this is
the thing that I did I shortcut it the
success part and went straight to the
suffering part and if success came
without suffering I felt like it wasn't
worthy I felt like I hadn't worked hard
enough to get it and I
then had two things that I needed to do
so not only did the event need to be
good not only did it need to run well if
it wasn't a success I was a failure and
if the success came and I hadn't
suffered I was also a piece of so
there was two ways well that's that's
sort of akin to impostor syndrome right
like it was successful I didn't really
work for it I don't really deserve this
people are going to find out that I
don't really know what I'm doing or is
that something different perhaps I feel
like there's probably a of a veneer of
of impostor syndrome in there too but
this felt it felt more visceral than
imposter syndrome and it wasn't anxiety
around it not happening well next time I
me not being good enough it was just
that I needed to suffer and that's what
this Puritan work ethic thing does man
and it's a hell of a drug especially if
you're if you're from one of the
Imperial Colonial powers that you can
imagine you know in the Middle Ages
these priests and they're ho the ground
and the sun's beating down on their back
and they're doing it in service of God
it's not about the work it's about the
suffering you know and they've got a cat
a Ninetails and they're flating
themselves we're Sinners we're bad
people we need to be punished let's fog
ourselves let's do it in the context of
our work and make that a spiritual
practice but without the spiritualism
without any of the spiritual payoff and
that was where I got to and you you also
said two other things that I thought was
really really interesting and this I
thought about this when I I spent a bit
of time in CrossFit and I saw a lot of
people in CrossFit talk about uh
suffering and discomfort and stuff but
if I told them to sit on the couch for a
full week and not
train they would have completely gone
crazy and you said the real discomfort
is to see what it would be like without
the suffering and Tim has this what if
it was easy yeah uh line yeah that's
that's the discipline people always say
to me like how do you do these ultra
distance events and how do you have the
motivation to get up every day and
train and the the math in their mind is
that that's where the discipline comes
into play what they don't realize is
like that's what I want to do that's
what I prefer to do actually certainly
there's days you don't want to do it and
you have to call on a little bit of
discipline but that's my joy the
discipline comes in when yes you're like
today's a rest day you're not allowed to
go do that thing that you enjoy doing or
you know you're going to sit and
meditate for third for 30 minutes or
you're going to write something and you
know you're going to walk away from it
and not edit it or you're gonna maybe
only spend half the time you would
ordinarily preparing for a
podcast you know what I mean that's hard
doing that going the extra mile is
rote that's second nature to me
yeah yeah
I it's it's fascinating I I find this
this Quirk of a particular type of human
very very fascinating but I think a way
to a way in is to think of it in the
context of flow States and by that I
mean can you inhabit a state of allowing
can you be an open Channel and in uh a
disposition of surrender where you are
receiving receiving almost like an
antenna as opposed to willing things
trying to make them happen uh again I'll
take it back to recovery I mean one of
the first things you learn is your
powerlessness over drugs and alcohol and
that the solution is not going to come
as a result of you applying your will to
this problem which or taking drugs and
alcohol it's like self-will run Riot is
what yeah it's like s it's like I read
that book
you guys I get it whatever I'll figure
it out don't worry about it and you're
trying to solve a problem of the mind
with the mind that created it and you're
going to do it by applying this
incredible self-will that you have only
to discover that you're digging the hole
deeper and deeper and deeper until
you're so broken you let go and you give
up and you
say I can't do this alone please help me
not only do I need help I want help I'm
willing to receive help and I will take
the uh instruction that's given to me
which requires a tremendous amount of
humility so are you in
self-will is that self-will out of
balance with your life and what would it
feel like and look like to release your
attachment to that self-will as an
engine of identity and instead be in
that very uncomfortable state of being
and allowing you've talked about your
relationship to endurance
racing mutual friend of ours will gu
recently ran across America yeah what
you make of will G I love will G I think
he's great I think he is an interesting
and compelling breath of fresh air into
the ultr running Community um just by
way of background I have some experience
in Ultra endurance events I've done a
bunch of hard races over the years
um so I have uh a connection to that
Community I know a lot of people in that
Community I have a lot of friends in
that Community um Will's BFF in in ultr
running is our mutual friend Robbie
Bellinger who ran across the United
States has done a lot of hard things set
the record the F the uh fkt for the
central how many laps of the Cal how
many miles you can run around the loop
in Central Park in one day like he's
done a lot of crazy wild stuff and those
guys couldn't be more different uh and
yet are the closest of friends train
together race together they crew each
other's Endeavors and it's a really
beautiful friendship that I I've been
sort of privy to to witnessing and
observing um I know Robbie a lot longer
than I know will uh but I followed will
it was Robbie who introduced me to will
originally uh so I started following
will online and uh I just found him to
be so so unique as uh a figure in this
strange little subculture of ultra
running because that is a culture that
historically has been populated
with you know guys that uh you know live
in the van down by the river know how to
grow a nice beard um it's a granola
crowd it's a very it's a very it's a
very in a beautiful way it's a
Grassroots
Community uh that has
um that has uh you know participated in
and helped grow a sport where typically
there's no media coverage there's no
prize money nobody's doing this for
Glory or media attention you pitch a
tent at the starting line the night
before you wake up you do your 100 miles
and you go home and and nobody else in
the world knows what you did except for
you and there's something really pure
and and amazing about that and and and
uh and that's sort of woven into the
fabric of what this sport is about here
comes will G male model six-pack abs
looks a lot more like a rugby player
than an ultra Runner he's got you know
the shaved torso and the uh skin care
routine that he's happy to share with
you he's walking the catwalks he loves a
nice bathrobe and a five-star hotel and
tea Service uh he enjoys the Finer
Things in life good British gentlemen
yes at the same time he's an absolute
beast when it comes to ultr running uh
fueled by a desire to make peace with
the early passing of his mother who who
died of cancer and to raise money and
awareness around cancer research he
begins participating in these Ultra runs
uh mostly I think he started doing some
marathons and he he did the the Jon o'
GRS run he did a couple hard things but
then created some self-styled Adventure
for himself ran around Lake Como and
this past summer ran across the United
States no small feet 3,000 miles Robby
was there every single day supporting
him uh reys Robinson uh was the guy who
created the weekly Vlog on the audacious
report which is the YouTube channel that
they have ree used to work for me he
lived at my house he created videos for
me so I know these guys really well and
it was super fun to watch will throw
down day after day 52 miles 54 miles 56
miles and do it with a
smile and a certain
flare and a passion for fashion this guy
looks good and as hard as that
was there's something inside me that was
thinking he he's kind of making it look
easy and this in turn ruffled some
feathers out in the ultra running
Community I love this want to
know about these fethers that you know
there's a certain idea of of of what an
ultra Runner looks like how they're
supposed to be and will isn't will is
very different from that and I think
people don't like different and so there
was a a sort of who is this guy and what
is he doing um and then on message
boards people
started uh taking shots at him and there
was a little uh movement about whether
or he was actually doing this
legitimately okay so skepticism around
the actual skepticism yeah so much so
that one guy flew from the United
Kingdom and showed up they were I don't
know where they were in the middle of
the Navajo Nation or something like that
convinced that Will was
cheating and that he was there to root
him out it's a story that will shares on
my podcast I don't know when this is
going up and I'm not sure when my
conversation with will is going up but
um and will had to kind of weather that
on top of the difficulty of just
actually competing this very difficult
task uh and so which he did and he did
it again with flair do you have a I
think it's a British record perhaps it's
not a world record but I think I don't
even I don't remember offand I could
have looked at up yep um I think that
was part of what ruffled feathers that
he was going to be the fastest British
guy but there was this other guy it's
like who cares like will doesn't even
care yep you know he just wanted to go
do this hard thing and raise money and
um
experience it with his friends and you
can watch the weekly Vlog on the
audacious report and see how it all went
down but I respect will
for his
conviction and his sense of self to just
be who he is unapologetically do you
know he reminds me of Ross
Edgley a little bit uh I love Ross Ross
is great my not so much in the way he
looks or the way he dresses Ross is like
permanently in Ross is Ross is a lot
sillier he's an absolute animal in the
way that he trains mad respect for Ross
and and and his accomplishments I think
he's just in you see his one in uh
Italy yes yeah and now he's back in
Byron Bay Training um but Ross is Ross
is I think Ross has a a more childlike
nature to him that's very endearing uh
but yes similar in that they've cut
their own path in Endurance Sports
not So Much by participating in other
people's races or sanctioned events but
by creating their own self-styled
Adventures what's the endurance
community's response to Ross being
because he did he for the people that
don't know Ross swam for about 200 days
six hours on six hours off without
stopping right all he circumnavigated
the UK the first man to web a swim
around the UK he has recently tried
twice and successfully in combination
with with Jim shock to complete the
longest ever single duration
swim uh first time in Loch NES too cold
second time in Italy too hot yeah uh
this African Heat Wave comes in and the
water temperatures 32 degrees the air
temperatur is 40 degrees so it's
unbearable anyway what was the endurance
community's response to this guy who
trains Chris Hemsworth looks like a
bodybuilder crossed with a salty old Sea
Dog is a always
laughing I didn't see any any uh
negative stuff about him but I wasn't
looking for it either I don't know
surprises me yeah I mean he's a he's a
very affable guy um people especially in
Open Water Swimming can get very
particular about rules and how these
things are conducted there's a whole
controversy around uh Diana niad when
she uh did her Cuba swim to Florida some
people say she broke the rules it
shouldn't count Etc so there's there's
some personnic kind of you know attitude
around these types of things I don't
have a sense of negative blowback on
Ross um maybe there is maybe there isn't
but I think to your point of the
similarities between will and Ross like
Ross doesn't look like an endurance
athlete either he's built like a tank
and yes he trained uh Chris Hemsworth
for Thor he's just an absolute unit this
guy which is not the kind of uh uh
physique that you want to have for
longdistance Open Water swimming and
I've told him I'm like why are you
putting on all this bulk you're making
this harder for yourself if you lost 20
pounds of muscle your shoulders wouldn't
get tight you lose a little bit of power
in your stroke but when you're going for
uh Ultra endurance that's not important
what's important is efficiency and your
ability to conserve energy but he is who
he is and uh I I love him to death I
just think he's a delight to watch and
I'm always cheering for him yeah I uh
I've really enjoyed watching Ross his
book uh the art of resilience for
anybody that's going through a bit of a
tough time if you've read or listened to
the obstacle is the way enjoyed it and
thought I want more like a spiritual
successor to that book is the art of
Brazilians from Ross So stoic Sport
Science I think he called it yeah yeah
um and it's sort of
semi-autobiographical
diary of his swim around the UK where he
applies both stoic philosophy lessons
and sports sence to the narrative
awesome and he's a great writer
he not a contributor to GQ like he's
been writing for a long time I think he
has a sports science degree um and he's
done a lot of crazy stuff like he did a
l Triathlon like K yeah log swim he
pulled a car you know like he's done a
lot of kind of Jack LAN type stance over
the years this episode is brought to you
by a product I've used every single day
for over three years now and that is ag1
it's a foundational nutrition supplement
that covers whole body Health helps with
my energy my digestion and is a staple
every single day in my supplement regime
you don't need a handful of pills or
potions one tasty drink every single day
that covers all of your nutritional
bases this is why Andrew hubman and Lex
Freedman and Joe Rogan and Rich R all
are massive fans of ag1 they've upgraded
the recipe 52 times over the decade
constantly improving to make sure that
they create the number one foundational
nutrition supplement on the planet also
they've got a 90-day money back
guarantee so you can buy it and try it
for a full 3 months with one pouch per
month and if you do not like it on day
89 they will give you your money back
that's how confident they are that you
love it if you're looking for a simpler
effective investment for your health try
ag1 and get five free ag1 travel packs a
year Supply vitamin D and that 90-day
money back guarantee head to the link in
the show notes below or go to drink
a1.com
wisdom that's drink a1.com
wisdom I've heard you say before the
prize doesn't go to the fastest guy it
goes to the guy who slows down the
least that pressure of potential and
pressure of consistency to me in all
areas of life you know you were
specifically not talking about racing
you were talking about this uh on
off uh burn and Coast workload thing in
professional life how do you deal with
that you know you've got this engine
inside of
you I want to work I I I care about the
work that I do I care about the things
that I do I want to serve all the rest
of it how have you learned to switch
yourself off and what's the journey
being like
to releasing that right foot from the
accelerator pedal it's it's it's been in
interesting lesson
uh that I have reluctantly embraced I
guess I would say um but you can't serve
to your maximum effect if you're not
also serving
yourself so you have to tend to the
vessel if you want to be a vessel of
good in the world and when you're a
workaholic or you're someone who's prone
to suffering and feels like your
selfworth is tied up and going the extra
mile being in that place of Letting Go
and allowing yourself
to take time and step back is the most
counterintuitive thing that you can
possibly do again that's the discipline
but the truth is to the point of that
quote the prize doesn't go to the
fastest it goes to the person who slows
down the least that was originally said
to me by my coach my endurance coach in
Ultra endurance there's nothing about it
that's
fast you could go out and run a mile
right now faster than any of these Ultra
Runners but if you were to run a
10minute mile which is easy for most fit
people uh 130 times over then you would
crush the bad water and probably break
the record so it's not about fast it's
about the ability to
persist and your ability to persist is
correlated with your capacity to
conserve you have to be able to meet out
your energy in small bits in order to go
the full distance I'm somebody who's
always thinking about the longterm I'm
not somebody who's trying to create a
viral hit or make a big splash tomorrow
I just do my daily work every single day
and I trust that as I continue to get
better at what I do that I hone my craft
and that my focus is squarely placed on
the things that are most important that
the success will come eventually and as
a result of that as opposed to
engineering success in some kind of
FastTrack way I think that's misguided
it may be effective in the short term
but what are you doing 10 years later
and I want to be somebody
who can continue to do this thing that
you and I both do for as long as
possible I've been doing it 11 years as
you know it's taxing it's a lot I don't
think it's as is uh easy as people think
I think there's so much work more work
that goes into it than people realize
and in order run that Marathon you have
to take breaks and it's scary to take
breaks because if you're not doing then
who are you the world is passing you by
you're going to miss out all this uh
forward momentum suddenly gets
arrested but I have learned
that taking that
time ultimately becomes a growth
accelerator because that time is
necessary to not only recharge your
battery but also to develop clarity
around the how what and why of what the
you're doing so about four years
ago uh I decided to take a month off
sabatical terrifying I went to Australia
for an entire
month and yeah it was terrifying I mean
it was great too I was in Australia
what's not to love uh
but to not open the laptop to
not edit the blog post to not engage in
any of
that was perhaps the most uncomfortable
I'd ever been and it's not a switch that
can just get switched off and it's not
something
that um gets easier even a week later
like you really do need a lot of time
like I needed that entire month like it
wasn't even actually until the last week
where I started to
feel a little bit more grounded what did
you
do uh I kept it really simple
I mean I have friends I was in Sydney
that year I've gone I've gone to
Australia twice so I've done this every
year I've gone to Hawaii twice and all
those places I have lots of friends lots
of opportunity to do fun stuff and see
lots of people and blah blah blah but I
really treat it
like a retreat and so I live those days
quite monastically I do what I enjoy I'm
in a tropical location I get up I make
my morning smoothie and then I go out
and I train I ride my bike for four
hours I go to the ocean and swim um I I
push myself physically and then I come
back I eat I would I go to the beach I
read watch a movie go to bed at 8
o'clock and and try actually not to talk
to anybody and to not be
online
um if there's any output at all it's
just in journaling
with intention and those pages
ultimately creating the foundation for
an idea or something later but besides
that no work what have you learned about
your direction or your goals or yourself
through these
manaries one a very tactical level I've
learned to trust my team and that I can
let go so that in and of itself that you
can take a step back and the
whole castle doesn't cave in on itself
and the world continues to spin and the
work gets done um is
incredibly comforting and
empowering
um because it taught me that I can step
away and it's not going to be a
disaster
uh I don't think that you
can have the level of clarity on who you
are and what you're doing
when you're in the
minations of the creative process
there's a myopia like you're what you're
doing six interviews in four days or
something like that and then I mean
you're on a hustle grind right when
you're on the hustle and you're on the
grind there's a a sort of euphoric
feeling that comes with that and sense
of Pride and and accomplishment that
that's all good but you're not seeing
the forest for the trees because you're
staring at the leaves on one particular
tree uh and so in order to have that
perspective you have to stop and if you
don't you're robbing yourself of the
greater opportunity that's right in
front of you because you've created your
own treadmill for
yourself and it becomes very easy
especially if you're getting success to
just keep doing that thing but sometimes
you have to pattern interrupt in order
to
identify the greater opportunity or the
orthogonal uh opportunity that you can't
see when you're in the midst of the
grind there's
a cognitive bias I guess a a framework a
mental framework called Direction Over
speed and the lesson is that
if you are going in the precise right
direction regardless of how quickly or
slowly you're always making progress mhm
if you're not going in the right
direction very quickly you can actually
push yourself further away from the goal
that you ultimately want there's another
Insight from Chris Sparks who is a world
champion poker player and a productivity
expert uh and he says there can be no
growth without goals and it's a really
nice counterbalance he he came out with
it just after James clear's atomic and I
I would love to get those two guys
together to talk about this um they
don't conflict they they mesh nicely but
I do think it's an important redress um
as soon as James
said you do not rise to the level of
your goals you fall to the level of your
systems as soon as he said
that I think that and the success of the
book which was
phenomenal and is in one of my top it's
still like the number one New York Times
bestseller it's phenomenal yeah it's
it's a it's a Powerhouse and right so
right it's it's one of my five books on
myund book list that you have to
read as soon as he said you do not rise
to the level of your goals you fall to
the level of your systems I think people
stopped thinking about goals and he made
a really great argument which was
everybody at the start line of the 100
meter race has the same goal it's to win
so it's not the person who has the best
goals it's the person who has the best
systems and preparation that's
true as you dig in a little deeper it
forgets about Direction Over speed and
this is what there can be no growth
without goals that Chris meant which is
that it is
just personal goal mental masturbation
for you to frenetically do
self-improvement not in service of a
thing or not in service of even a
direction that you're going toward and
it was a really important reframe for me
and I think that it plays into what
you're talking about why would you take
a
sabatical if not that there was some
direction that you were going
in I think
that the discomfort of relinquishing
control over the day-to-day work uh
especially if you enjoy even if you
don't enjoy what you do like it
butresses your selfworth in a lot of
ways and uh yeah taking um taking the
manuary holiday that would be I I think
that would be my equivalent of an ultra
endurance event I hate running I hate
running I got invited on a gym shark run
we're out here in uh LA and I got
invited on a gym shark run with Noah
Olsen and like some other cool people
that I'd probably love to meet I could
think of anything worse I don't want to
go running but I would rather do an I
would I would genuinely rather prepare
for an ultra race than try and take a
full month off which is exactly why you
need to do
it or you can ride this Pony until you
fall off and you're about to crack and
break you're young you're
robust uh I'm sure your capacity to
handle a lot of stress and an extreme
workload is is very large uh but I think
there's a Breaking Point to all of that
and I guess my point is that you don't
need to get to that point to recognize
the value of stepping back and I think
if you reframe it
as as not a break but as call it
whatever you want that makes you feel
better about what it is that you're
doing um I think it's important to do
that short of now I do it whether I feel
like I need it or not it's a
prophylactic against burnout and stress
dude the only Ripple I would say before
let me finish this thought uh to the the
kind of James Clear thing that you were
that you were talking
about just to be clear like I'm not
using that month to set
goals per se I may but that's not the
intent that I'm bringing to it the
intent that I'm bringing to it is to
step back look at my life in
all the categories and ask myself what
the are you doing like why are you
doing this and to really deconstruct
that why and to figure out if
there's a more evolved
way of doing what I do or maybe a new
Direction Al together I don't set
fiveyear goals I'm not somebody who's
like I'm trying to do this thing I'm
trying to be nimble and responsive in
the moment to what is happening and the
more I am in connection with
myself then the more trustworthy my
instincts are about that
directionality and I've learned over
time to trust and rely upon that as the
barometer
of not just the the T that I'm taking um
but the steps that I'm executing on to
get there and I think that served me
well and has allowed me to Pivot and to
uh not be afraid to experiment try new
things play with the format with the p
it's like it's successful don't change
it just keep doing the same thing right
but if doing what I'm doing in the exact
same way I was doing it six months ago
that I'm not growing so it's an Embrace
of experimentation a healthy
relationship with failure um and holding
things looser not holding on so tight
it's the tight hold that I think you
probably have right now uh that you're
so resistant to releasing it's way what
you're talking about and I'm glad that
you clarified it's way bigger picture
than goals it's way further up what's
important to you what are your
values what is the quality of the
relationships that you have where were
you six months ago or six months ago
where did you think that you would be
now and is that lining up and if not why
what's the missing piece in your life
what's the thing that brought you Joy as
a kid that you've pushed aside what is
the most uncomfortable
conversation with yourself that you've
been running away from your entire life
do you have the courage to engage with
that are you willing to do a little bit
more work can you pull back another
layer on who you are are you man enough
to do
that we all have stuff we don't want to
deal with stuff we compartmentalize or
we think well I just put that one way
and I'm not going to worry about that
I'm
good true growth true expansion and
ultimately your highest expression and
the manifestation of your greatest
potential is inextricably connected to
and linked to that willingness and
courage to do that stuff that you don't
want to do I've heard you say do you
feel that to enjoy your life is an
Indulgence that's fine for other people
but you're on a mission so you can have
a different relationship with those
aspects of life that other people find
important yeah I can fall into that trap
and have uh it's convenient it's also
ego
satisfying uh I don't need to take a
break take a day off that's for other
people I'm doing this thing and this
thing is important and people care about
it and I'm willing to sacrifice my
personal health in the short
term so that I can get that person on at
the last minute and put that episode up
and so many people are going to be
impacted by that there is a uh outsized
sense of self that gets packed into that
kind of narcissis yeah there's a there's
a maniacal narcissism with that um I
like that I like that yeah and so you're
not really that important the internet's
not going away nobody's waiting for your
content they may enjoy it they may get a
lot out of it it might be very
meaningful to them it might have changed
their life but
ultimately that narrative that story
that you're telling yourself is really
just a convenient
excuse
for avoiding a level of self-honesty and
self-connection that will ultimately
create a stronger better version of that
person you're deluding yourself you
already
are yeah I I really think that you take
your endurance
athlete perspective it definitely seems
like you're applying it to most of your
other Pursuits as well and you know in
the same way as doing a a race for
250k no one's going to do it in one go
okay so when are you going to break and
for how long what's that going to look
like and what are you going to do during
it um one of the things that been
thinking about a lot is protecting your
passion
um you can continue to put your nose
against the grindstone and sacrifice on
the Altar and flag youate yourself for
the thing that you see as your
calling but it becomes progressively
harder as you erode your passion and
protecting that just tempering that foot
on the gas can allow you to use a much
more potent fuel which is the passion
side of it which is getting fired up and
being excited to go and do the thing and
I got this conception of a an hourglass
shape to a lot of independent creation
Pursuits so at the very beginning uh
everything is kind of easy because
there's no expectation you're doing it
exclusively For the Love of it you're
only doing it when you want and nobody
cares and then as you start to achieve
success you get squeezed more and more
and more because there is expectation
and maybe you're making money from it or
maybe people your sense of self- Worth's
attached to it or maybe it's your
identity it squeezes and squeezes and
squeezes and squeezes and then it gets
to this point in the middle of The
Hourglass and I do think that as you
break out onto the other side that is
largely a function of Revenue but can be
a function of other things as well
including experience that you can afford
to delegate that you can learn to
delegate that you can learn to
relinquish and as you come through the
other side you go okay well now maybe I
don't need to do absolutely everything
maybe I can have somebody that can keep
everything taking over while I'm away
and this can happen in business this can
probably happen I would imagine that
mothers feel this with children when
they need to have faith that the father
they can go out with their uh girl
friends you know 12 months deep into the
baby being born and they can leave it
with the father and the father knows
which way up the baby's supposed to be
and how to change a nappy and when it
needs feeding and so on and so forth
there are a lot of things that I think
occur within this sure what I would say
to that is you can be on the upper end
of that uh
hourglass
um
metaphor and you could still be a
and be fueled by anger
and resentment and Spite and ego yes if
you have a successful Enterprise and you
have enough Revenue you can hire people
you can delegate you can create
convenience for yourself um that's all
fantastic and it's something that I'm
doing now and I'm reaping the benefits
of that and I highly recommend it but
I'm getting at something deeper which is
what is your fuel source there are lots
of different sources of energy and
motivation for why we do what we do most
people I'm convinced are are navigating
the world reactively completely de
coupled from who they are without any
self-awareness of why they're responding
and reacting to the externalities of
their environment in the way that they
do and I think a lot of people live
their life that way there are other
people who invest in themselves enough
to try to understand like hey when I do
that this happens maybe I shouldn't do
that I wonder why it is that I do things
that way that excavation can lead to a
healthier
um uh way of responding to the world and
and decision making Etc uh but you can
still be acting out of resentment and
ego Etc this process never ends it's the
worst it's the most annoying thing
there's no end to the amount of
self-standing and and kind of Behavioral
modification that we can engage with but
I think for me that top end of The
Hourglass is a situation in which
one has
transcended the lower energies of
motivation because they're unhealthy and
also they're unsustainable anger is a
very powerful fuel source and it will
catalyze a lot of activity and in some
cases a lot of success but at some point
that fuel source is going to either run
you into a pit or you're going to run
out of that fu I had this exact
conversation with Alex yesterday
saying he he's a big proponent of use
what you have and most people have way
more resentment and anger than they do
hope yeah I do
agree for activation energy to get
yourself out of whatever the zero to one
stage is you need to use what you have
because zero to one is the hardest the
first thousand subscribers the first
blog post the first whatever it is that
you do is always the most difficult one
so use what you have the problem is if
you find that that fuel source is potent
you can end up relying on it over time
and the problem is it's toxic when you
own addiction correct yeah correct um
and it has its
own
euphoric byproduct when you engage with
that anger there's something exciting
about that and when you have success
doing that you're going to go back to it
and you're going to go back to it and
you're going to have to run into an
obstacle before you decide to change
that way yeah I called this the vestigal
pattern bias it's technically referred
to as the Ein Stelling effect but
basically the thing that you did when
you started that gave you success you
refused to let go of when you no longer
are served by it and a lot of people
find success by grasping on really
really tightly but the delusion or the
Li is that that is the source of the
success and the same way that a lot of
people a lot of creative people when
they get sober think they're never going
to be able to write another song or be
able to perform in front of people or
you know paint a picture or whatever it
is because it was the drug that was
giving them the inspiration and the
spark that that um allowed them to be
their best most artistic self it's the
same lie whether it's anger or
resentment and the fear is if I clear
that out if I transcend my anger if I
make peace with the people in my life
and I let go of these resentments and
I'm in a place of
forgiveness then I'm going to have no
ambition what's my fuel yeah and I will
my business will crater and my life will
be over and I think that's a very real
fear that a lot of people have and I
under I understand that um as
counterintuitive as it may sound my
experience has been quite the opposite
and I've been lucky enough to witness
people's lives Blossom and explode in
the best way in miraculous Ways by
overcoming those character traits or
Character defects that they once thought
were sources of of fuel only to learn
that they were hindrances and and
anchors when liberated from that there
is a sense of capacity that expands uh
that then creates a life
that's ultimately bigger than the one
they could have imagined for
themselves what would you say to a
person listening to this podcast or your
podcast who spent a lot of time in their
head that enjoys the power of their
thoughts and being able to wrang Wrangle
the world using cerebral horsepower and
cognitive
effort and feels like I probably need to
kind of get out of this head and kind of
down into this heart and be able to
actually hear me not just hear my
thoughts Sam Harris talked about uh
having ideas and systems and the uh
equivalent of someone who is reliant on
their cognitive horsepower letting go of
those would be the equivalent of them
being hit over their head with a hammer
and say I love my ideas and my systems
you would your life would you should try
them you should my your life would be
amazing if you and he had systems and
ideas like mine what what do you say to
that person that's kind of praying at
that altar of cerebral horsepower I
think there's so much to be learned and
gained from engaging with the heart mind
I myself as somebody I you know I lock
myself in my head I'm
very uh enamored of my own ideas and my
ability to articulate them and write
them down and my ego loves it when I a
certain phrase Etc I get that I
understand that and our brains are
pattern making machines and our
intellectual capacity is what we
leverage and rely upon in order to make
sense of the world around us and who we
are we create rules through our
perception that gets processed through
our mind and that becomes the definition
of
ourselves and what the world is and the
expectations that we have of others
to mute or quiet that and
instead attune your attention to the
heart is a very
esoteric and um challenging notion to
even understand like what does that mean
or what exact what's the tactic like how
do I do that there you're back in your
mind already right was there a p to of
Titans about this yeah I know right
so what's interesting about this is my
my wife is like all in her heart and I
think with certain men I'm perceived as
somebody who is very heart-centered but
my wife looks at me as as a guy who
lives entirely in my head like because
the contrast between us is pretty
significant and she's been an amazing
teacher and helping me to to make that
connection that I find so difficult and
in times of Stress and Anxiety I will
inevitably default back to because it's
so hardwired but I found that when
I'm when I give myself permission to get
quiet through meditation through
mindfulness
practices uh to listen to
myself and do and try to if there is a
practice to it it's really um not
necessarily like a rebirthing but trying
to connect with that child you know what
is your earliest memory what is it that
brought you Joy as a young person what
did you like to do that you even that
you forgot you even liked doing and the
more you can kind of ground it in that
context and learn to listen and be
silent and get out of the way as opposed
to allowing your your ego to intervene
or to make people understand that you're
here and you have something to say
um quiet can you get quiet can you be
with yourself are you good company for
yourself are you haunted by your brain
is your brain working on overdrive what
would it feel like to let go of that and
listen to the subtle
energies that internal voice that you
know lives inside of you but you're so
quick to Snuff out because you have
stuff to do and you're an important
person and you got to call that guy and
you got to check your bank balance and
you got to
go online and see how much that car
lease is or when am I going to be able
to upgrade my condo to this house all
that is just getting in the
way of
that authentic real version of
yourself it's kind of down there going
hey buddy I'm here don't forget
me the feels very feminine and I think
it's probably challenging for a lot of
guys it just
feels antithetical to what it means to
be a man or their notion of masculinity
But ultimately I think is just an
unbelievable source of strength and
growth and capacity and
creativity
[Music]
um that when
nourished uh
really might surprise you and I know
that when I it's it's counterintuitive
for me Chris like I like to live in my
head but when I allow myself to do that
those are the moments that have been
fundamental and critical in
these um Transformations that I've had
in my life they have not been functions
of the intellect they have
been functions of the heart and
appreciating what that aspect of myself
is trying to tell me about about who I
am heating it taking action on it those
have
been that is at the foundation of every
Quantum Leap that I've made as a human
being rich I love it let's bring this
one home man uh it's been a very long
time coming I'm really really really
glad that you came to see me today I
feel like I
uh letting go of that cerebral
horsepower is something that very very
many people myself included listening to
this podcast probably need to take heed
of I'm really really glad that you've
got
this other side of you this other
contribution where should people go they
want to keep up to date with the stuff
you're doing and what's coming up next
uh everything I do is at rich roll.com
Rich Roll podcast on all the places Rich
Roll on YouTube
Etc and uh that's it check out my
podcast similar to Chris's but different
uh and I really appreciated this today I
really thought you asked amazing
questions and and uh you forced me into
some uncomfortable places so I hope I
acquitted myself uh adequately but I
appreciate the opportunity thanks man I
appreciate you cheers thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode with Rich then press here for my
full 2hour podcast with David
Goggins